Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
and to reimagine the Caped Crusader in
the most realistic way possible
including his take on Batman's arch
nemesis the Joker sight-gags and
over-the-top practical jokes
Tuukka backseat to more realistic
depictions of a domestic terrorist
hell-bent on watching the world burn so
we had to ask what would actually happen
if the Dark Knight's Joker had to stand
trial in a court of law for his crimes
and the Dark Knight Gotham District
Attorney Harvey Dent's entire mission is
to clean up the city from filth and
corruption like the Joker but even the
Joker has a right to an attorney so we
needed to talk to a defense attorney
about what it would be like to represent
the ultimate agent of chaos my name is
Doug Ridley I'm a criminal defense
attorney I run my own law firm and I
started out my career as a prosecutor in
the District Attorney's Office The Dark
Knight Joker is in my estimation the
most disturbing Joker out of all the
ones that we've seen this is someone who
doesn't live in a reality in any way
shape or form and has his own twisted
vision of what the world is he's twisted
in a way that we don't see in our
criminal justice system typically
speaking Joker's crimes are numerous
throughout the film
but arguably his most heinous act of
violence comes when he threatens to blow
up a major Gotham Hospital it's Wayne
Enterprises employee Coleman Reese isn't
murdered within the hour with such a
grandiose display of destruction does
this move beyond the jurisdiction of the
Gotham City PD when the Dark Knight
Joker ends up going to a position where
he is bringing in explosives and blowing
up things that triggers a new level of
investigation and a new level of
prosecution we're dealing with federal
charges in this case we're dealing with
ATF Alcohol Tobacco Firearms who is the
investigative body that oversees
explosions and explosives so this really
is a true terrorist activity much more
so than any of the activities that we
see any other Joker's going on live TV
to announce your acts of terrorism
doesn't seem like it would help your
case very much in court
is there any maneuvering your client out
of this because the evidence in the case
is so strong really the only hope for
Heath Ledger's Joker is to plead
insanity and while typically we don't
see a lot of not guilty by reason of
insanity pleas in cases this is the case
for it he is so deranged and so
separated from reality he's doing this
because everything else is boring he's
doing this because wouldn't it be fun to
set up this game where they want to kill
the guy or blow up the hospital and he
is so far separated from reality that
really the only chance he has is for a
not guilty by reason of insanity defense
but an insanity defense is not the
easiest strategy to enact if you were
prosecuting how could the insanity
defense be torn down in a case where I
was prosecuting and trying to beat a
claim like Heath Ledger's Joker is
insane what I would want to do is show
that he did understand the consequences
of his actions
he knew absolutely that what he was
doing was horrible and awful and evil
and that's why he was as calculated as
he was so the level of calculation the
level of evil that he had potentially
shows that he's doing it intentionally
so I would argue as the prosecutor that
that's the reason why the insanity
defense could be beaten this Joker
clearly loves to talk look at these
scars you know how I got these scars
would you put him on the stand to
testify in his own behalf in order to
sell the point that maybe he's not all
there the decision on whether or not to
let Heath Ledger's Joker testify or not
really comes down into all of the
pretrial aspects of trying to get the
insanity plea handled and processed
through the court and he would need to
be fully psychoanalyzed he would need
tests and doctors and multiple reports
and all that would come in the biggest
wildcard is you're dealing with that
level of Joker and that level of
insanity and he's shown that he can
outsmart darn-near anyone that sits in
front of him
so all of those aspects of it would come
into play and my hope would be not ever
putting him in front of a jury not
putting Ledger's Joker in front of a
jury might be a safe bet for him and
more importantly an even safer bet for
everyone involved with the trial whether
it's blowing up a judge poisoning a
police commissioner or even killing his
own cohorts the Joker has shown that if
he knows that you're going to come after
him he'll get you when you're not
looking how do you find and more
importantly protect potential jurors and
lawyers in this case the aspect of
protecting all of the people that Heath
Ledger's Joker would have access to is
almost impossible it's one of the
reasons why I would want to put this
through the court as far as getting the
insanity plea handled rather than even
introducing the element of the jury
luckily Batman is around to keep the
peace and ultimately bring the Joker to
justice but while Batman may seem like
the answer to the problem of the Joker
his presence in this case may cause
problems for the prosecution there are a
handful of things that the element of
Batman brings into a case if I'm
defending the Joker
when Batman's out there doing his
vigilantism he's not always following an
exact police procedure
the problem is when we see a meeting on
the rooftop with Jim Gordon then that
increases the chances of a guy like me
arguing that he is actually an agent of
the police and so those same
constitutional protections unlawful
searches seizure and all of the things
that we afford to criminal defendants
would come into play in a case like that
one of the aspects that makes Heath
Ledger's Joker so frightening is that he
enters Gotham City like a force of
nature was no discernable way to find
out his true identity no matches on
prints DNA dental clothing his custom
the labels I think in his pockets but
knives and lint no name no other alias
so the question becomes how do you
charge someone with a crime if they have
no real identity it's an interesting
problem when we don't know who he really
is
without fingerprints without any sort of
way of identifying
and what I would typically see in the
case like that if I were prosecuting it
or working with the investigation is
what we would see is they would go a
little deeper than they did in the dark
night and they would do some DNA
sampling they would test his blood and
that would potentially bring up some
hits assuming at that point that for
some reason he's just completely off the
charts they would create a new fictional
John Doe with his fingerprints whatever
he had left with his DNA blood type and
that would be his the start of his
permanent record in our system it
wouldn't stop him from being prosecuted
but it would make it really interesting
from a law enforcement perspective so in
the case of Gotham City versus John Doe
assuming Gotham City allowed it would
the Joker ultimately be looking at the
death penalty there's no way that Heath
Ledger's Joker after blowing up a
hospital and killing people the way that
he did he absolutely would be the person
who would get the death penalty as his
defense attorney though I'm gonna argue
that he's insane that he's absolutely at
a break from reality and so therefore
rather than killing a person in
retribution we should be dealing with
the fact that he's insane and giving him
the treatment that he can on the other
hand Joker's a special kind of evil who
especially in this in this case and
especially in the Dark Knight and so
it's really hard to put a real-world
overlay with somebody who's that
maniacal and that level of crazy what's
such a high-profile catastrophic reign
of terror how long can a trial for this
version of the Joker linger in the court
system I would want this to be a quick
open-and-shut case the shorter amount of
time that it could go on the fewer
problems the fewer opportunities for
other people being hurt the it would
just be better for everyone including my
client but the reality is just finding a
prosecutor I think is going to be
challenging on a case like this just
finding a judge is gonna be challenging
on the case like this because Heath
Ledger's Joker is so scary and has such
a reputation of taking out anyone that's
involved this is something that's going
to take years and years and years to get
developed and actually get in front of
or so for crimes of this magnitude
committed by a man this dangerous to the
public the possibilities ranged from
insanity to the death penalty if fear of
the man himself doesn't grind the system
to a halt before a trial can even begin
who which is exactly the sort of chaos
the Joker would love to see why so
serious why so serious indeed
[Music]